qué quiero expresar con mis fotografías artísticas
y cuál es el sentido de hacerlo?
Cada tanto me preocupo por
cómo medir el impacto que tiene el arte
como lo hacemos con la medicina o la tecnología
dónde podemos ver los resultados y calcularlo.
Entonces finalmente sería capaz de explicarle a mi madre mi arte
con números reales.
Pero mi arte está muy alejado de cualquier medida
y sobretodo, mi fotografía expone ampliamente el tema del escapismo.
Mi teoría es que a todos nosotros
a veces se nos dificulta escapar
para analizar nuestra realidad,
apreciarla o cambiarla.
No trabajo con la vida cotidiana tal cual es,
y no soy fotógrafa de documentales
en el sentido tradicional.
Pero soy fotógrafa de documentales
en un sentido diferente.
Documento los sueños.
Trabajo con la vida cotidiana como podría ser,
como yo la imagino.
Soy una soñadora, pero al mismo tiempo amo todo lo que es auténtico
y lidia con nuestra naturaleza íntima,
de la cual jamás querría escapar.
Me encantan las personalidades complejas,
y la vida real me inspira a crear mis imágenes.
La vida real inspira nuestro escape,
y a veces ese escape es muy necesario.
Creo que los héroes no se crean fácilmente
y elijo trabajar con individuos
que son sobrevivientes
y que enfrentan rutinas diarias
que no siempre son muy coloridas,
gente que está en camino a una mejor vida,
luchando contra las circunstancias de la vida.
¿Por qué elijo a personas así para que sean mis modelos?
Porque también he estado en esa posición,
cuando tuve que aprender a sobrevivir en la vida real.
Yo era una estudiante viviendo en el exterior, en Londres.
Trabajaba en dos lugares al mismo tiempo como camarera.
Obviamente, no era mi trabajo soñado,
pero decidí jugar un juego
en el que imaginaba que tenía un papel en una película,
y en la película era camarera,
y necesitaba actuar muy bien.
Solía teñir mi cabello y mis cejas de pelirrojo,
Cambié mi pelo por rulos permanentes,
perdí peso
y me obligué a creer
que era un personaje en una película.
Eso no es para siempre,
era solo temporal.
Esto me ayudó mucho.
Me motivó a cambiar mi vida
y a tomar los tiempos difíciles como un juego.
Ahora, como artista,
creo vidas diferentes para mis modelos
para darles la experiencia de ser otra persona en la realidad.
A través del proceso fotográfico,
todos mis modelos se convierten en actores de película muda.
Son capturados en el momento
en el que creen ser alguien completamente diferente.
Para crear una nueva realidad en su totalidad.
Creo físicamente cada pequeña parte de mi trabajo,
desde los atuendos hasta la escena.
Porque trabajo con analógicas,
y no hago ninguna modificación digital a mis fotos,
necesito que todo se lleve a cabo en la realidad,
a pesar del hecho de que hoy en día,
digitalmente, se puede crear casi cualquier cosa.
No me gusta este camino.
Incluso si este alcanza la perfección,
yo veo la belleza en la autenticidad de hacer
y eso es imposible sin las fallas.
Una foto manipulada digitalmente
no es verdadera para mí.
No captura nada real.
No fue vivida, no es motivadora.
Es como si en vez de viajar,
uno mira las fotos del viaje de alguien más.
Lo que encuentro emocionante
es la habilidad de volver realidad los sueños de ser otro de las personas.
Es como una droga
que me empuja a seguir trabajando,
incluso sin tener medidas.
Una de mis modelos
siempre había soñado ser vista como una guerrera,
pero no podía hacer deportes por sus problemas de salud.
Hace medio año, falleció
por su enfermedad cardíaca a la edad de 22 años.
Pero dos días antes de su muerte,
las imágenes en las que pasamos meses trabajando juntas
de ella como la guerrera en la que soñaba convertirse
fueron publicadas en una gran exhibición en Milán por la Revista Vogue.
Toda su vida se trató de superación.
Antes de morir, ella supo
que miles de personas vieron su imagen de la tierra del escapismo
y creyeron en ella cómo una valiente guerrera.
Para mi trabajo, invito a la gente a jugar un juego
como todos lo hacíamos cuando éramos niños
cuando pretendíamos ser alguien más
y ese proceso nos hacía muy felices.
En mi opinión, es importante para los adultos.
Necesitamos estas transformaciones
para promulgar esto en el nombre del arte.
Nos hace sentir realmente importantes y poderosos
para influenciar nuestra realidad.
Lo sé gracias a mi propia experiencia personal.
He tenido tantas versiones de mí misma
a través de mis autorretratos
que he sido muchos personajes distintos.
Ser alguien más en la tierra del escapismo
no precisamente proporciona números que podamos medir,
pero es como una forma real de magia perdida
que existe, pero no puede ser medida.
Existe un poder único en el arte
para transformar y levantar nuestros límites.
El arte crea lo que llamo vida invocada,
que ayuda nuestra existencia
y nos empuja, motiva e inspira a vivir
y a expresarnos
sin medidas ni cálculos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)